hello everyone we would like to get
started if everyone's ready
my name is Raven and I am one of the
volunteers for pi data Seattle as well
as a member of the organizing committee
for this conference so this tutorial is
titled Hands-On intro of ipy the Zoo
Story a new open source charting tool to
build create and share animated data
stories with python in Jupiter in this
tutorial uh one of the creators I have
right next to me will introduce their
technology and help the audience take
the first steps in utilizing the power
of Animation in data storytelling this
tutorial will provide a direct practical
experience for the audience so it will
be a Hands-On tutorial there will be
time to get into groups or individually
to actually Workshop this technology and
then at the end of the workshop there
will also be room for presentations so
participants can show the stories they
build and also receive feedback so I'd
like to introduce Peter vidosh to you uh
Peter is the CEO and co-founder of the
zoo his primary focus is understanding
how the zoo's Innovative approach to
data visualization can be put to good
use listening to people complaining
about their current huddles hurdles with
building charts and presenting them is
his main Obsession next to figuring out
how to help data professionals utilize
the power of Animation in dataviz
involved with digital product
development for over 15 years earlier
products and projects he worked on cover
mobile app testing online analytics data
visualization decision support
e-learning educational Administration
and social
still building a selfie teleport just
for fun is what he likes to boast about
when asked about previous experiences so
please help me enter uh give a warm
welcome to Peter
hello everyone I hope my mic works does
it
great great first things first so thanks
very much for having me I'm so glad that
so many of you came uh I never had a
workshop with with so many participants
and since we're developing this uh all
the time uh there are new content coming
up so there's going to be a lot of
things that that we do here for the
first time and uh as you can imagine
with the new technology you can expect
things to break to not work properly uh
to have to have issues with that uh and
and I you know I try to prep in a way
that that I can still help you go
through this painful points and actually
there are some colleagues of mine uh
back in Hungary which is uh in a nine
hour time difference so it's it's eight
o'clock in the evening for them uh who
are prepared on slack to help you out uh
if if you you get stuck uh so um yeah
first of all a couple of questions to to
you know get to know you a little better
uh how many of you are working as data
scientists right now please hands up
like uh half of the room how many of you
use computational notebooks uh like I
don't know regularly like Jupiter
almost everyone that's great uh how many
when how many of you have to have to
present uh your findings so contents
from a notebook to somebody that's not a
data scientist say a business
stakeholder uh very regularly hands up
uh uh I guess like 50 50ish
how many of you and since we're on
Microsoft premises this question is a
little awkward but still I have to ask
how many of you screenshot your plots
that are in the notebook and then just
copy and paste them into PowerPoint uh
to show them
okay looks like the same amount of
person almost that have to present this
that's that's the most uh practical way
of doing that so I I totally understand
uh and uh yeah how many of you use
streamlit regularly to build apps
hands up
like three four people okay and uh
lastly how many of you have heard about
vizu before coming to this Workshop
uh one two person two people great I I
love uh to to introduce our tool to new
people so the the as as Raven said the
way I planned it to go down is uh to
talk a bit and then to give you the
floor and and help you go through the
the painful process of learning
something new I my intention here is to
to really just help you get through
these these initial steps that are are
usually hard to take when when you're
getting acquainted with some new
technology uh but first a little bit of
background like why we have this
animated charting tool that runs uh in
in computational notebooks and actually
in streamlit now as well so basically
what we have
is a generic chart Morpher uh it's uh it
uses the same logic to encode all
different types of charts and because it
does so I mean visu this engine it can
interpolate between the charts that are
expressed on this interface
first logical question would be like why
on Earth anyone wants to build such a
thing other than making a cool animation
like this
I would say effortlessly but we have to
build the engine in the background so
after we were done with that the the
animation was was easy to build
the reason for that is we have a vision
we have a vision to build a graphical
user interface for data it's actually
not intended for professionals like you
but for people using Excel
uh we we want to enable them to be able
to explore data visually uh to tell
stories of the data and actually build
animated data stories as a byproduct of
their analysis to reuse these views of
data sets and reports and dashboards and
also to use them as for forecasting and
and and planning which is nice but we're
still not there yet what we have is this
engine that is more flexible than than
anything we've met so far frankly and
that can be used for for certain
purposes
um like for example data storytelling is
the most
like a profound or the most
straightforward utilization or use case
for for our technology and especially
for those who can code as of this point
a little bit of History so in 201 2020
and 2021 we developed the core engine
which is in C plus plus we used it
in-house to build data stories and
interactives with it in September 2021
we released our first open source
product which is for JavaScript
developers so basically an open source
JavaScript charting tool with which you
can build interactives and and animated
data stories and then roughly a year ago
we ended up starting to focus on on you
guys so on on people on data scientists
and people with experience in with
python and that's when we released one
of the tools that I'm going to show you
today called ipivizu and there were a
couple of strong feedbacks we received
initially
which was about like okay it's nice but
how can I use use it and so pretty soon
we released an extension to it called I5
is a story that enables you to build
present and share animated data stories
within computational notebooks such as a
jupyter notebook and and you know that's
how I ended up here because it turned
out that even though you still
copy and paste or screenshot and paste
charts from computational notebooks some
of you have shown interest and and the
organizers of this conference also shown
interest in in what we do and and you
know I just try to spread the word and
understand how our thing can be more
useful for people like you again we're
in early stage companies so actually the
two two of my co-founders and myself are
full-time on this project there are a
couple of people helping us out so as
you can imagine we have challenges in in
making it fully flat uh production ready
thing but but I think we've come quite
along the way and and lucky for us we've
been uh we're coming very close to
closing an additional funding round in
the next month or so so uh why do we
want animated charts that's another
logical question uh to our understanding
static charts are quite abstract uh you
have to and especially people without
your expertise have to always understand
what they see and make the connection
between different views of the same data
set so like for example these four
charts show the name same data set and
uh and if I connect them via animation
then the connection between these views
is is obvious you don't have to think
about it whereas with the original
static way uh you know you have to
explain what's on the chart or as a
non-expert you you have to like
understand each and every View and try
to make the connection between the views
in your head some of these use cases or
things that you can show using animation
you can drill down and show components
of a composite index for example and and
show the the difference of a component
to to
yeah more composite part you can you can
show part to whole and and show if if
like one element is going against the
trend
um you can these are just example you
can you can switch between aggregation
and distribution again very intuitively
these are all things you can do with the
current tool you can show change over
time like using this uh this racing bar
chart these were so popular a couple of
years back that they were banned from
the latest beautiful subreddit because
basically everybody was posting things
like this there and you can actually
turn one chart into a whole story so
this one shows the initial pie chart
showed the the number of smartphones
different companies are selling and then
we added the the revenue they generate
which is obviously uh uh like it
separates these companies into into
Super into different classes and and you
have a sense of magnitude uh compared
comparing Apple to basically any other
company that produce that is produced
using smartphones
we have a lot of Integrations already
with notebooks with uh with with the
softwares coming out from the Anaconda
ecosystem like panel and Pi script with
a bi tool like more than and I think the
most interesting one is that we have
with streamlit I will show you a couple
of examples why I think that
and without further Ado let's get down
to coding and seeing you know actual use
cases of of uh of IPI visu if you go to
this link I also added it in the talk
notes or not like you can find it in the
schedule uh it will get so it's bit.ly
and visu hyphen Pi data hyphen Seattle
so and if you follow the link you'll end
up in this uh this repo folder uh at
visual HQ slash visual workshops this is
a specific folder I set up for you
there's a warm welcome there because I'm
happy that you're here and that you're
there as well and then there are a
couple of links and you have all the
notebooks that I'm going to show you in
the notebooks folder some of them are
for presentational purposes and some of
them for you to to fiddle along okay
any questions until now
at any time any point in time by the way
if you have a question just raise your
hand and and and I'm happy to to hear
you out uh just like Raven said I really
want this to be interactive and I don't
have any problem with being uh being
interrupted and I can talk for more than
90 minutes about vizu and that's
definitely not my intention so please
interrupt me okay so
I5 is the basic logic of ipivizu it uses
a single method called the animate
method you call it once and then it will
give you a static chart you call it once
again with a different configuration and
then it will animate that chart to the
new state that you've just described so
it's pretty straightforward it has a
three arcs or objects the data so you
add the data to your charts the
configuration of the charts and The
Styling and optionally you can you can
fiddle with the animation options you
can change those as well we really try
to make the animation as smooth and and
easy to follow as we can depending on
the different settings of the charts but
it doesn't mean we're right all the time
and as you can imagine this thing has a
huge parameter space so there are a lot
of different settings where we might not
made a good job and and you know in that
case just play with the animation
settings and and let us know how how we
should make them better or yeah there
can be other other
like cases when you need that first
example the Titanic data set you can
install our thing using paper conda and
it actually works with a pandas data
frame so here I'm going to just import
pandas and import the chart data config
and style from ipy visual as you can see
and read a CSV file that's the Titanic
data set that I assume most of you are
very familiar with we just added one
column called count which is the the
value one in each row and then we create
the data object here and add the data
frame to the data object and then you
can see the contents here so first we
create an empty chart by creating an
object and and then setting the width
and the height of it depending on what
kind of notebook you're using you might
need to have different settings so I
would encourage you to go to ipivus.com
if you if you need to set something up
and then go for uh like here is the
environments section and there are the
notebooks so it's ipiviesel.com will
take you to this documentation site and
within the notebooks you can see plenty
of different notebooks and other
platforms uh with with detailed examples
like detailed instructions and how to
make it work so I'm not sure what kind
of notebook you're using but this is the
way to go forward uh if you if you want
to uh you know try and and use what we
have here and let's build our first
chart so I let you in on a secret this
default geometry of the elements that
are being shown is rectangular elements
and we are going to just add the count
so you know one per passenger to the
x-axis and then the sex of the
passengers to the y-axis and also the
count on the label of the markers what
do you think we'll end off with what
kind of chart we will have any guesses
bar chart horizontal bar chart
um yeah you're right
so if I run this cell you know the the
count is on the x-axis ah yeah that's
that's what I was looking for and then
the sex is on the y-axis and that's it
uh next up I'm going to uh call the
animate method once again and add the
the survived category uh again on the
x-axis and also on the color of the
markers these are channels here and uh
yeah ipadvisor will simply just animate
to this new state where we have this
stacked bar chart uh the the
um these bars have been split whether by
uh the this category whether the uh this
passenger died or survived and lastly
I'm just going to remove the survived
category from the x-axis and add it to
the y-axis in in the last step which
means that the categories will be listed
on the y-axis and we will have a grouped
bar chart instead of the Stacked chart a
couple of things notice here so even
though we had we had this continuous uh
like data series The Count uh I5 is
automatically aggregated that so we have
a couple of uh passengers who were
female and died who were female and
survived and whatnot and and everyone
has the value of one and ipadvisor just
automatically aggregated uh discount
value and that's what's uh represented
by the width of the bars and it's also
shown on on the markers because we added
to delay we added it to the label
Channel
um in the configuration part and firstly
we're going to focus on this thing there
are a couple of other things you can set
for example the geometry or the
geometric elements used to represent the
data I'm just going to turn it to Circle
and rerun the cell and now instead of
the bars we have circles and because we
have circles we can add something to the
size of these circles we're going to add
the same value the count and as you can
see now the the horizontal position and
also the the the size of the circles
represent the same value and we can even
switch the coordinate system from
euclidean which is the default value to
Polar to end up with a chart that make
no sense or at least it's very hard to
understand that's that's what you get
when you have a generic charting engine
right you can build a lot of different
types of charts that that people might
not understand and and they're just not
very
widely used and thus understood but but
that's fine uh I'm pretty sure you will
notice and and you have most of the data
scientists I had the chance to to have a
discussion about Visual and charts with
uh were very familiar with the you know
the familiar chart types and wanted to
only use those because they know that
they knew that that's what business
people will also understand so I'm
guessing you won't use this thing so the
configuration part which is the most
important one we have the access X and Y
we have some channels color label size
and lightness and so you can actually
add any number of categorical series to
these axes and channels and one
continuous series and you have endless
opportunities to to come up with
different types of charts and then we
have other parameters like the geometry
that I just showed you we have the
coordinate system Cartesian or euclidean
you can sort uh in certain settings by
value uh the the the the elements that
are being shown you can align them
differently you can add the title we
already use that so here uh we added to
title passengers of the Titanic and then
you know it it was kept to the very end
and there's another option called
splitting that I'm going to show you so
basically another thing to remember is
that uh ipadvisor will only change the
parameters of the chart that you
explicitly change when you call the
method like so for example uh the the
sex was on the y-axis by default and
when I change the category and the value
on the x-axis it the the value on the
y-axis remained there or I set the title
In the initial step and and it's still
there even after the third step it's
this it works the same it employs the
same logic with styling with data with
everything you only change what you
explicitly change okay
uh that that's about it now I know that
this intro session or this intro part
can be a little fuzzy right how should I
know what kind of geometric elements to
use and in what way to build a bubble
plot or to build a violin chart or you
know these are not connected but uh bear
with me in the next bit uh in the next
part of this I will show you uh chart
presets that actually do this specific
thing so starting with a chart type and
then just filling in the blanks to build
those with with iPad visual but first I
really like you to get some sense of the
configuration part and and have some fun
with that so this is the playground one
uh notebook that you can find in the
notebooks folder I would definitely
encourage you to to start playing with
that it uses a data set that contains
information about every country in the
world and their population from 1953 to
2098 we have data points for every five
years we have a period data that tells
us if that data is from the past or if
it's a forecast and we also afford the
forecasted data we have uh the three
scenarios so population medium high and
low this is all from the un's population
forecasts and uh and if you if you go to
this notebook uh like yeah there here we
can just we just create an empty chart
and I add some styling features you
don't have to deal with those I repeated
all the information about the
configuration here and then I added some
cells here that you can basically play
with just be feel free to change from
area to Circle to line to area to switch
the coordinate system to switch the
value being shown and in the next cell
again to to change different settings of
the charts just so that you understand
uh what you end up with I'll give you a
couple of minutes for those of you who
have a laptop in front of you and would
be happy to give it a go and then in the
meantime if any of you have some
questions just let me know let's say you
have I don't know two three minutes to
start try it with different settings and
if you have any issues so something
doesn't come up so first things is
um go and join our slack Channel which
you will find the link in the uh the
iPad is an intro I should have put it
here but if if you click on the slack
link it will invite you to our slack
then if you post anything in the help
Channel if something is not right my
colleagues will will help you out right
away and
also
um yeah basically that's about it
how many of you would actually want to
give it a try right now this example
notebook
please hands up okay there are around 20
people great the floor so it's all yours
uh I I hope it's gonna work well for you
if not
get get on slack or raise your hand and
I'll try and come and help you out any
questions right now
okay none so far
so yeah then to give you some examples
that I I just showed here uh you know if
you change and and for those of you who
are not playing with it so if you change
the population medium to population low
for example and we run this then you
know we we will see a different forecast
uh that than than we originally did uh I
now change it to population high and and
yet that's yet another forecast uh you
can change so now it's it's an area
chart you can turn it back to rectangle
which will be a column chart you can
turn into Circle what whatever you want
I won't use the polar coordinate system
because it won't make any sense right
now as well you know in pie charts with
donut charts with with with uh yeah
Nightingale the polar coordinate system
is great but otherwise it's not that not
that common uh and and in the next bit
uh I just add the region which is sort
of like continent to the y-axis and also
on the color so now we will see uh
the color uh the the uh the different so
the population forecasts for different
uh regions on the screen interestingly
they are now accumulated so whenever
you're using a circular chart like this
one you might not want uh to uh use the
the circular elements so I'm just going
to add the option here and use
um
area chart
rerun the cell yeah this makes more
sense right this is this is a stacked
area chart and a funny bit part that I I
told you about the the splitting feature
so if I if I turn it on then we will get
to this view so we can see the
components side by side uh and and you
can you know see the trends of those and
and and when you turn it off you can
yeah looks like this with the alignment
uh there are a couple of ways to play
with it so you can align it to the max
which doesn't make so much sense yeah
I'll get back to you in a second uh the
most interesting alignment option I
think is the stretch one which will
switch to percentages instead of values
so it's that easy to switch between
values and percentages uh so this was
the the original view that we had and
yeah with the stretch we can see the the
uh the share of these components and
there was a question back there
is that right
what
I couldn't find it in the document
um so the question was where you can
find these options so for the
configuration options right that's
that's what you refer to
um I'm well we we have them but maybe
it's not intuitive enough uh in the uh
in the documentation side so if you go
to ipivus.com you'll end up at the same
side that I'm right now where where I'm
now at and in the tutorial uh it
actually gives you a step-by-step
introduction of ipivizu so first about
the chart settings then adding data and
then here are the ways to use the access
the X and the y-axis to use the
geometric elements within the config
part so it's it's it might not be listed
as well as uh as on this notebook uh for
for experiment that I put together for
experimentation but you can find all the
options here and also you can check out
the code reference but I think it's not
that straightforward so I would stick to
the tutorial and and these example
notebooks that I've put together for you
for orders okay yep please
uh if I'm happy with the sequence of
transformations uh is that possible to
export this as a image tube and
the question was if you like the
sequence of Animation how can you export
that so that was one of the questions
that we had very regularly initially
when we released i5 visu and the answer
to that is ipive is a story so yes and
we are going to get to that very soon
any more questions right now
okay let's move on with some more
advanced stuff is that okay for you
cool so we are going to now use chart
presets I'm going to give you a little
bit of introduction into styling and I'm
going to show you how to use fillers the
next data set that we're using contains
information about how much revenue
different music formats generated over
time in the US a couple of things again
to notice here and I'm referring back to
my original comment about having a small
team and building an open source tool
and you know so first of all you have to
specifically tell IPI visu that year is
a category otherwise it would think it's
a value and we would end up seeing
charts that we don't want to see so
whenever you have numerical numeric
values in a data series there are
actually categories and year is the most
common example of that just when you
actually read the CS3 into the data
frame add this option there and it'll be
fine the other thing you might notice is
that I in the beginning so this is is
all arranged from all this to newest
this is something you have to do with
vizu right now with i5 visu and also
there are
elements here with the value zero so we
have uh I don't know streaming in 1973
sadly it didn't generate any Revenue we
have to add it there so that we have the
right order of the categories otherwise
I the way I5 Visa works is that it
processes the data frame and we would
end up having the categories in the
first order in the order where you know
either meets with them from top to
bottom which is a lot harder to to
understand when you want to properly
prep and and visualize your data so I
encourage you to to as at least in the
top of your data frame have all your
categories listed in the order you want
them to appear on the chart with the
value zero if they don't have an initial
value that's totally fine
next step we create again the the empty
chart here
we we set the width and the height and
we add the data to it and now we are
going to use a preset a bar chart preset
so we have config.bar it looks the same
as it was before so we have X in the y
axis but we know that it's going to be a
bar chart right now we have a lot of we
have a list of presets here let me
quickly go back to that page so you can
within the examples category on the
documentation site you will find the
preset charts we have a lot of different
chart types as you can see and as I like
lollipop and scatter plot and bubble
plot and violin and vertical stream
graph and you know whatever we have a
lot of different chart types we can work
with and if you click on any of those
you'll get to a sample code how to
utilize that chart type and uh and yeah
you can play the creation of the chart
once again and uh here's some info on
how to set up this chart what kind of
data it uses and everything we really
wanted to make it easy for you to get
started with all these different chart
types and and basically what I did here
is I told him that I'm going to use a
bar chart and right now I have a
not very nicely looking bar chart to say
the least uh and so uh what I want
firstly is to to have a different uh
color use the different bar which is the
group bar chart I just use the group bar
uh preset here and then I have this
option called Group by and I added the
format there and it means that it's
going to use a different color for every
bar
still I don't like the looks of my chart
so that's when The Styling thing comes
into play so basically we have a styling
hierarchy a styling structure that is
looks a little bit like CSS so it's
hierarchical and you can set plenty of
different things like the number format
or add a unique color palette by adding
a list of colors that ipadvisor will
employ
and yeah change the font size or
whatever so let me really quickly run
this cell and as you can see uh the The
Styling change the colors are now nicer
the numbers are shortened down they are
also applied on the x-axis and yeah
there are a couple of things you can you
can also change here so first of all
like I don't know you can make the title
a little bigger and as you can see even
the style changes are happening in an
animated manner so it's easier for you
to to understand what you have just
changed you can change I don't know the
the font Family Two Times New Roman or
aura or even wing dings if you want that
oh yeah right that looks nice doesn't it
and yeah let's switch back to times
General I know that it's so much better
but at least we can read what's on the
screen
um you can you can change things like
the fill opacity of the markers uh you
can actually change the background color
to make it very ugly like this one
um and and yeah and and a lot of other
things like that so to help you with
with finding the right styling options
for you we have a couple of things it's
it's not that straightforward I know I
know first of all you have a Google
spreadsheet
um which is if you go to the iPad with
the settings here it it actually has
this hierarchy that we use in the
settings and you can just you know
change the font family to Ariel you say
this area and then it generates you the
code here in this uh in this uh cell
that you need that you that you can
employ uh or just you know copy and
paste to your notebook like this
and now we switch it back to Ariel uh
and and I really need to make the the
background color look nicer because this
is indeed very ugly so I'm just going to
try and use white and two three four
five six yep
okay yeah it's a lot nicer and I also
don't want the fill opacity to stay this
way uh and and the other thing we have
and I actually uh I I gave the links
here on the top of this notebook so the
stunning parameters is the spreadsheet
and illustrations it's just like a
Google photos folder this is for uh like
a design for the UI that we will build
very soon to help you with the chart the
standing options and here you have like
it it tells you what part is what where
the title is where the panning is and
and what what are different options it's
it's actually very apparent when you go
here so like what's the y-axis label and
what's the marker label and and and
things like that so we try to help it
might not be super intuitive right now
but we try to help you with everything
we can uh I'm gonna show you a couple of
other uh presets so this is the bubble
chart for example looks really nice this
is the stack bubble chart and here I
turned on this feature called tooltit
tip so if I move on to hover over my
mouse over any element I can see the
value there then I use the the stream
graph here
and uh yeah I you know the x-axis labels
they don't really look very nice and
this setup so I'm just going to change
them
by changing the x-axis label font size
and the angle and oops as you can see
they are now aligned like this which is
a lot better still they are very tightly
packed so I'm going to use an event
which will set it so that only years
that are divisible by five remain on the
chart these events are still in
JavaScript we will we plan to add them
in python as well all I'm trying to say
here is that you can change any
parameter of the chart using these
events and you can find examples of
those as well now I'm again using the
splitting feature that I already showed
you before
and here's the filtering part so data
filter it's you just add an expression
again still in JavaScript but it's
really easy to use this one I set it
that the format is vinel or streaming
and if I run the chart like this then we
zoom in so we filtered out everything
else and only the streaming and the
vinyl remained on the chart zooming and
filtering is a really really useful
feature I think you just describe what
you want to stay on the chart and
ipadvisor will animate that and actually
the zooming animations is really really
good to direct the the audience's
attention so I would encourage you to
play with that a lot
um
and then I'm in in one step I'm going to
just split the the filtering off and
also the splitting this is the step that
my wife calls when the elephants kiss
now you know why and uh yeah and I'm
gonna turn this into a line chart uh so
you can obviously compare the trends and
and and see what format was ahead of the
other in in in different times uh now we
have another sample notebook uh
playground too for the presets The
Styling and the filters the data set is
the same uh you create the chart and
then again I gave you a couple of like a
preset here's an option to set the
custom styling and some ideas to to play
with those and and you know a couple of
other uh other yeah opportunities uh to
play with actually this one I think so
feel free to to play with those those of
you who don't want to do that I'm going
to just show you the content of this
notebook as well so here I'm creating a
an empty chart showing the population of
Africa it really doesn't look very nice
right now uh so I think
maybe this no it it made it it made
things worse
um yeah it looks like there's some
issues with the styling whenever I want
to something is like in a way that I
don't want it to be I go back to the
original state and I recreate the chart
and then all the changes that I made on
it will just go away whenever you have
an empty chart by the way so let me show
you a couple of let me show you one
example so I I'm instead of number from
a prefixed I I added something gibberish
there and if I run this cell then I end
up with an empty chart so an easy way
because of the JavaScript charting
engine being in the background is to
turn on the developer tools of your
browser and go to console and here it
says that there is an error because this
is not a valid name for it's either
grouped or prefixed for the number value
and so you have a hint and an error
message that you can use to to figure
out what's wrong with your chart
whenever you end up with an empty chart
it's usually something with the
configuration that you uh you you didn't
use quite well it can be I don't know
about the hierarchy of The Styling thing
I I ran into these error messages all
the time so I expect you to do the same
but uh this the the console in the
developer tool can help you a lot in in
figuring out what's wrong there and so
yeah the and and usually if you edit
like now it still didn't it still
doesn't work so I just go and restart
the whole thing create the empty chart
and then create the the working chart uh
I think uh yeah that's about it the next
uh I'm going to turn this into a line
chart at least I hope yep that shows
already the sub-region of Africa so
Eastern Middle northern southern western
Africa now I'm going to turn it into a
percentage area chart to show you how
the person so like the the population of
the sub-regions of Africa changed over
the year but whatever so you can use a
stacked column chart here instead
like this and but it means that yeah it
also has this special option of stacked
by so it can remain the same and then
it's a stacked column chart there are
issues with the labeling in presets so
we add labels there even if they cannot
be seen very well uh we will we will
deal with those you can actually make
them make the labels Disappear by
turning them invisible I will show you
an example for that but I know some some
of these presets don't work exactly the
way you would expect them to do
um any questions right now
um should I leave you some more time to
fiddle with this notebook or shall we
move on to actually create our first
story with the presentation bit
who wants the story
okay then we move on with the story bit
uh and
yeah I'll show you this one later
I5 is a story is the answer to your
previous question uh because we realized
uh you know people data scientists when
they present something they don't want
to show notebooks business people freak
out of notebooks you know that very well
now we know that too and the other thing
is you know I I really don't know what
cell when to run and if I go back and it
and I don't end up with the same chart
that can be an issue so that's why we
created this additional Logic on top
where you have slides that can contain
one or multiple steps and a story is
basically a collection of these slides
and the step is the same thing that the
chart was so we're using the same syntax
everything is the same except you don't
have animation options
I'm sorry about that uh soon we will add
those but that's not a very commonly
used uh feature of our tool anyway and
the other difference is is that you have
to add all the data to the story uh at
first so with with the normal iPad
visual with the chart you you could have
had new data series and and and new uh
new elements in within the your data
frame here you cannot do it you have to
add the whole data set in the beginning
so for example it's not very good for
when you want to put it together with
streaming data and expect people to
follow along as new data is coming in I
would use the original ipadvisor to do
that in in every other use case it it
works pretty well so again another data
set just a CSV file you can find it
obviously within the repo folder it
shows information about how much money
the US federal government spent on
things uh like titled r d like hell
space science energy national resources
and defense
um and uh yeah I just create a style
object here that I'm going to use
throughout the story this might be a
good way if you want to you know look
want to make the looks of your charts
really nice so to to set the styling
separately and just you know change this
uh as a separate object I create the
story object here so not a chart but a
story I add the data and the style to it
and I set the size it's it's very
similar to what we did with the charts
still we end up with an empty story
object so that's why we don't see
anything here and now we start building
our story so initially we just create a
slide with one step in it and as you can
see this bit is pretty much the same as
we used with ipivism so it has a data
filter so that we we don't include the
defense bit at the beginning everything
else is there so function doesn't equal
defense that's what this filtering thing
does and then we use the Stacked area
preset so we can use chart presets here
as well where you here is on the x-axis
the amount is on the y-axis and it's
stacked by function and in and then we
just call the add slide method of the
story to add that slide to the story and
that's it next we create another slide
called slide two where we turn the
splitting feature off and change the
title and then we add that to uh the the
story again and we we just switch on the
toolti feature we which we have again
here and we play the story
so this is how an i5 Visa story looks
like I just toggle full screen because
we have a button to do that it's on the
bottom right corner and now we have
these buttons beneath the chart with
which you can go back and forth between
the slides that you just created I can
use a clicker to do that so you know you
can
actually build these views and on your
own Rhythm while you're making your
presentation you can go through them and
and introduce and and illustrate what
you want to share uh with with your
audience that's really easy you can go
to the very end or to the very beginning
of your deck and that's about it so I'm
going to just really quickly go through
the other cells we have here because I
really would want you to you know have a
go at it here I use once again this
special Handler that would only leave
every fifth year on the chart because
it's very cramped the x-axis again and
here this is an important one so I
create a slide with multiple steps as I
said slides can have either one step or
multiple of those so I create first an
empty slide and then I call the add step
method of that empty slide and basically
just describe a step in initially I
turned the splitting off and then the
next step I will switch the filtering of
basically adding defense to the chart
and then I add the slide to the story
and I play it so I rerun I run this cell
now as you can see only every fifth year
is shown on the x-axis and I have now
three slides so if I toggle full screen
and
I can go so this was the initial view I
go to the splitting feature and here for
splitting off and defense appears
as you can see the U.S federal
government spent quite a lot on defense
as r d uh in in the last 70 some years
or so
so in the next cells I just switch on
the stretched alignment that as I told
you we'll we'll turn this uh so switch
to percentage View and then I'll just
add some more views that I'm going to
quickly show you but I just run all
these cells here and
so as you can see in all all times we we
add these slides to the story and we
when we run the story play we end up
with the initial slide so this is
something
that can be a little frustrating when
you're building a story so one of the
features that we will release now is
that you can add a special parameter to
Story play with which you can start the
playing of the uh the story at any slide
you want and you can add like minus one
which means it's going to start at the
last but one slide which is usually the
the way you wanted it when you're
building a story and so how the story
looks if in case you're interested in
what the U.S federal government spent
some money on is yeah so we have space
here this is when you know you send a
person up to the moon so the Apollo
program uh we we have health that is
like increasing all the time basically
um and then everything else is rather
small we have defense that's always very
huge and we we have obviously some so
this is I think uh Reagan's uh plan to
to you know um what was it called Star
Wars no well you know the program that
that made sorry it was
it was Star Wars maybe okay uh and yeah
so it's feel free to analyze it there's
like there are actually more insights in
this data set and then next up what I do
here is I do use the filtering feature
to zoom in on the first and the last
year that's in the data set uh and just
regroup the elements so that you can
compare which how which component
changed over the years uh and you know
it's it's fairly easy to to deliver a
presentation like this it's just one use
case there there could be a lot of other
stories and we actually built some but I
would definitely love you to build some
stories with this rather than us so for
example I just found a story on LinkedIn
that uh and actually a junior data
scientist guy who lives in Spain uh
built it's a it's a racing donut chart
about oil production so you know the
donut chart is good to show shares of of
the total and how it changes over the
years it gives you a sense of that is it
a good use case well he built it so it
must be good for something is it
something I would show to business
stakeholders
uh but you know it it makes sense it's
nice it's it's easy
and this is the sense that we would want
to give you that it's easy to build
animated data stories and to share them
and lastly here's this uh export to HTML
feature of the story and that's the
answer so the last bit of the answer to
your question how you can export it I
first initially I just set the size to
make it like as big as possible
depending on where it uh where it's
shown and if I run this cell in the
background an HTML file is being
generated I just open it up on my
computer here it's basically the same
thing and it has a story in it uh and
and you can you know send it in an email
or share it with anyone upload it to a
company server or whatever keep in mind
that this file has the data in it
so uh you're sharing the data in its uh
own structured row form when you're
sharing an iPad is a story like this uh
you might not want to share anything
publicly that's uh you know your company
the data yes a question there
thank you
especially for the python use case I was
just wondering like have you heard of
observable
um yeah the question was have I heard of
observable yes
um
okay so to my understanding of
observable because I'm not an expert to
tell you to to let you in on a secret I
I'm not a developer I'm not a data
scientist everything I'm telling you
here is I learned along the way so I
know about observable it was it's it's a
company that built a JavaScript notebook
it's founded by one of the original
contributors of the D3 charting Library
Mike Bostock and he's like a super uh
senior and and very well-known guy in
the world of of data visualization and
and and JavaScript uh usage and and data
storytelling uh I I guess I mean I
haven't seen people using observable
notebooks in my environment at all so I
don't know about the use case
to what my I so to my understanding it's
a good way to learn to use JavaScript
uh and and they are actually heavy on
that use case so they they like to
promote it like that you can build nice
bespoke visualizations but you have to
know uh D3 or at least a simplified
version of these three now I spoke with
many people who use these three because
initially as you know we had a
JavaScript charting solution and the one
thing they told me that it's it was very
painful for them to learn it so they
don't want to learn anything else that's
when we realized that uh we have
challenges in acquiring new users even
though uh people using JavaScript and
and and these three uh can build a very
nice data visualizations you can do
anything with D3 that you can use do
with visu actually but it would take you
a lot more time and a lot more expertise
so and and uh they are yeah they are
they only run in the browser they are a
special kind of notebook whereas for us
notebooks are integration environments
that come early on our path I can show
you and again I will show you some
examples of integrating our tool into
streamlit I know people at panel are
working on integrating our tool there uh
that that opens up new use cases for
dashboards and and reports and and I
have actually prototypes of integrating
our thing into Excel uh to to change the
pivot table editing experience there and
and a lot of other use cases so so our
thing is comes from a totally different
perspective than where observable is
coming from uh in the meantime uh you
have actually another playground called
playground 3 which is about the story uh
feel free to to fiddle with that why I
answer some of these questions it
actually uses the same so I'm just going
to run all the cells here and and show
you the story at the end uh
yeah a question over there
two questions okay
using one data set how do you use two or
more than two data sets and one story uh
you cannot do that as I said within the
story you have to add the whole data set
uh at the beginning you can build a
two-story objects and and then export
them separately and uh yeah we haven't
really started uh you know just uh
concatenating uh two stories together so
that they change switch from one to the
other so you might have two HTML files
at the end but those are two separate
stories that you've just described
I think you answered my second question
also my second question was if I want
slide from one story and a slide from
another story and get them together
so the second question was what to do if
I have a slide from one story and then
one from another story how to put them
together right now you cannot uh we we
are working towards that as well so we
understand that that storytelling and
presentations are an important use case
for for visu and I mean even though I
come from the country that came up with
the Innovation called Prezi which is uh
in browser presentation tool how many of
you have heard about that
okay I'll tell the Prezi guys they'll be
happy about that but still I mean
PowerPoint is the most widely used
presentation tool especially in a
business setting there is so we are
working on uh making it easier for you
to embed this kind of stuff within
PowerPoint initially it might be just a
way to to generate uh really a video
sequence that you can embed there and it
won't work both ways so you would only
be able to go from start to finish and
don't go back like like with the
interactive version but I know there are
ways to actually embed interactive
content within PowerPoint and we are
going to focus on that in in the next
period and that would obviously include
use cases where you have more stories in
one presentation you might want to add a
slides that don't even have a visual
chart on even though I don't really
understand why you would want to have
any slide without a Visa chart on it but
you might do and uh yeah so
another question over there yes and I'll
go through this so my question is
um so when you when you going like
inspect the elements for the HTML code
you can see the data but is there a way
to see the data like a tabular format
that's easier to read and like kind of
go through
um not with the exported HTML file so
obviously within the notebook you can do
that it's a pandas data frame so there
are plenty of tools you can use to to to
look at and even manipulate the data
frame with the exported story we haven't
added anything like that you know we are
trying to get away from the tabular data
in in some sense we are focusing on the
visualized data uh one more question as
of this as of now okay and then we I'll
have time for all of your questions but
uh I want to just move on in the
meantime with the other bits yes please
you know
um so the question is about the data set
was like eight kilobytes and then the
exported HTML was 40. 14. so it's like
six extra kilobytes
I'm glad to hear that so you know uh I
we we haven't really made benchmarks of
that uh it shouldn't be so much bigger
so actually you know the engine itself
is minified you actually use the
JavaScript engine that's so the library
itself is is added to the HTML but it's
it's rather small and all the uh the
views so the charts there are just
basically this bunch of code that the
the engine will generate within the
browser uh using webassembly so uh they
it there shouldn't be a size issue but
yeah it depends on the data set that
that would contain most of the infrared
there yeah sorry one one extra question
no no no problem
like hey here I have this other data set
here's an example
to get some general
simpler things we create some of this
code
um
I mean it seems to work like I just gave
it to the other data set it gave it your
first example yes
that's a great idea I I actually wanted
to save the announcement to the very end
so the one okay can we use chat GPT to
generate visual charts so this is an
awful version uh and and it's not
working that well but yeah you can
actually try using chat GPT
to generate some of these charts but so
before I I get lost in all the content
that I prepped I I promise I will show
it to you but let's try and keep on
track so we have the third this iPad
this is no this is the playground that I
created for you actually the story in
there it's pretty simple it shows the
population of the world between 1953 to
2018 so for those of you who haven't had
the chance to play with it it shows the
population of the regions it zooms in on
Europe
it shows I guess uh yeah some of the
regions and and they don't look that
straightforward and now it zooms in on
Eastern Europe which is where I come
from and it switches on and shows you
the countries so actually I I come from
Hungary right now uh I I mean it should
be a feature that if you click on one of
the elements and the legend and it
highlights and we had that in the
Prototype but it takes some more time so
we are not the biggest country in
Eastern Europe as you can see it's a
it's a Russian Federation and uh and and
Ukraine but this is a pre-war data so
I'm guessing especially on the Ukraine
part it changed quite a bit sadly and
now we can just see the uh
um the like the the high estimates for
that region and you can obviously zoom
in on any of the so just feel free to
test it with with your own
region or continent with your own
sub-region with your own country uh I
guess that's some of like a
personalizable data story that you can
build and so here comes the part where I
thought for those of you who want to
give it a go and test ipivizu I prepped
some data set some some data sets some
more than what we have planned like
played so far and
yeah I mean I I just added it in
playground four uh there's like the the
the population data set there's a music
format data set there's a data set about
the profane words and deaths in
Tarantino movies prepared by 538 so like
there's in uh time minutes in
0.61 time in reserve or dogs it only
contains information up to uh I guess
Reserve or dogs or like the first seven
movies or something so there are two
missing uh then I have another data set
about superheroes and their powers this
is actually two data sets that I didn't
have time to uh like uh Join one is
about the superheroes like their gender
their eye color their hair color their
race and whatnot and their superpowers
there's like a list of uh 168
superpowers and uh true and false for
those if they have them or not we have
the Titanic data set and here you can
just you know I I wanted to make it easy
for you to get started with adding any
data frame to a story set design filing
and start playing with it
um how many of you feel ready to you
know start building their own data story
while we're here or would like to give
it a go
a couple of hands up please
okay please start doing that and we
continue having a discussion and a q a
with those of you who don't feel ready
to do that I'm totally okay as I said
this is all very experimental I actually
think looking at you that yeah maybe
let's make something like you should
stand up and and move around okay
stretch yourself can I ask you to do
that usually if if we were in Hungary I
would ask you to start massaging the
person right next to you but I I I'm
afraid that it might be I don't know not
okay
culturally or I don't know so here just
please stand up and move around maybe
you it's okay to to stretch your to your
arms like this so do do this kind of
stuff and yeah I'm pretty sure yeah do
do a do like this it actually would do
good for you it's really not good for
your body to to sit in the same place
for such a long time my wife is a
physiotherapist so she should know at
least and uh and I'm trying to keep up
okay so now we we have the blood flowing
this is great
um
yeah I'm I'm sad to see guys
um guys before those of you who are not
who don't want to uh participate before
you leave uh there's one thing I usually
do at the very end of my presentation
but uh since I understand not everyone
is is interested in in joining in with
the interactive bit or with the building
a story bit uh would you be okay that I
make a selfie with a photo like where
all of you is present this is my way of
of proving those who my colleagues are
back at home that I actually came here
and did the bed uh so I'll just do a
quick one okay and for those of you who
don't want to be like recognizable on
the photo first of all you won't be but
uh you you can just look away or you
know move to the background I mean maybe
this is the angle where I can get the
most of you in the picture yeah it is
and just
now yeah so I'm usually very bad at this
even though I'm doing it for quite some
time so uh just say visu Okay so one two
three wizzoo
yeah I'll do a couple and we'll see how
it goes thanks I I really appreciate
that so
um then there are a couple of options to
go from here so first of all those of
you who want to build a story please do
I would love to help you in that in
doing so again my colleagues in the
slack would love to assist you with
doing so and uh and that's it for all
the others I'm happy to answer any
questions you might have usually people
have a lot of questions at this point
and I'm also I would be very happy to
show you some of the things that we're
working on like the chat GPT integration
and other stuff and lastly I have some
stickers so if that's your thing please
come and take as many as you want
um so let's let's try and split it up
who wants to build a story right here
right now just to get a sense of
ipadvisor hands up once again okay
how many of you need any assistance from
me at this point
okay please start working let me know if
I can help you if you want to team up
with others you're free to do that I
would love to see some thing I don't
know a couple of times yeah please
please take some if you want
um
let's make a vote of the other thing who
wants questions we have two options
questions first or new stuff first
uh so who those of you who wants the
questions to come first raise your hands
okay one two people those of you who
wants the new stuff to come first raise
your hands okay so it's new stuff coming
first then please start working on your
stories and for the all the others I'll
show you where we're heading uh I'll
meet a list so
um first of all we are going to add
animation options to stories I I really
haven't expected an Applause for that
but I just wanted to tell you secondly
we will add a slider so meaning that
whenever you have a this it's going to
be right beneath these arrows and you
can just move from one animation bit to
the other you can manually just scratch
the animation and get from one face to
the other this is just one way of making
animation really intuitive
um starting us at a pre-selected slide
number I already told you that we will
redo the API to make it more pythonic I
expect it to be done in the next one or
two months because frankly the the
biggest criticism that we get from
people like you is that this is a
dictionary based thing I cannot use tab
to understand what are the parameters
the specific chart types and I have to
know what are the parameters at certain
chart types and and that's not good so
like I'm I'm used to a different kind of
thing with matplotlib and with all the
others we get it we understand we are
not python developers especially myself
but we the other is neither and we are
happy to adopt we are happy to add this
sort of or new API for you uh so we
basically you will have a separate
method for each chart type with the
parameters that you can ask for using
tab
um
we will also add I'm going for the most
exciting ones a little later okay so
that you still stay here a little bit
um we're going to add some Integrations
or some examples on the side that are
called analytical operations we're going
to release that hopefully next week so
one of the things that we realized is
that people don't have too much
experience with building animated data
stories which frankly is quite
understandable at least until now and we
really try to help you in in making your
first stories and we realized that
actually many of these transitions these
animations we make are actually
analytical operations so things that you
do with your data you check the
distribution you you see the total you
drill down you want to see the the the
the share so the percentage is you want
to compare bits and things like that and
so we we actually made these transitions
for you so for example these are the
distribute examples and similarly to to
all the animated example all the other
examples you will have these animations
and these these these examples there for
which you will have the code and uh and
and some explanation on what's going on
within the chart and you would be able
to just replay the animation to
understand what's going on here and and
employ them to your
to your stories uh the other logic I
would want our team to to put together
is to go via chart types and not via
analytical operations so to see all the
operations for a line chart for example
because you know that's what easy that's
what is easiest for you to understand
like at this state I have a line chart
what can I do with the line chart
impress me give me some ideas and things
like that there's a question
can you uh can you do like a can you do
Geographic charts
um yeah in the zoo the question was can
we do geographical charts so Maps
basically
not right now but we're on it so we can
extend the functionality of our generic
chart morphing engine uh to Maps so maps
are also uh you know they are a special
they use just special shapes uh from our
perspective and uh actually so there are
plenty of things that that actually
worked really well in the Prototype and
at one point our CTO implemented uh
geojson import into visu we weren't able
to to transpose from a normal type of
chart to a geojson but it would it could
have been done but you know we we
started focusing on the JavaScript API
and we really have more things to build
than we can we can we have a team for
that's why that's one of the reasons why
the open sourced our thing so we really
would encourage you to to uh comment and
contribute and and you know integrate
our tool to new environments actually
most of the Integrations that you saw
were done by others uh in some cases
people we don't even know personally or
not even we haven't even been in touch
they just made the integration and and
and yeah committed it to our repo we are
obviously very happy happy to see
something like that okay uh I promise
you some other new stuff right
um
so um
yeah the the GPT part but firstly
streamlit streamlined integration so
there's
iPad is a story works out of uh books in
streamlit and it works really nicely
actually if you go to
blog.streamly.io you can find a rather
new piece that was just released six
days ago it was written by me it's a
very very long introduction of using and
but it's a step-by-step tutorial
basically of using ipy visual story in
streamlit it it introduces the logic
that you're already familiar with but
then then it just at the end shows you
some apps where ipadvisor is already
integrated so this is an app here uh let
me just open it up in a in a separate
window
um here we go
foreign
so basically this is an interactive
story in the sense it's all about the
world's population thing once again that
you're already familiar with so this
shows the world population in the past
and how it's gonna by region How It's
Gonna Change in the future uh and then
it it shows the component side by side
and then uh yeah the percentage-wise and
it zooms in on Africa but you can
actually select I don't know Latin
America and the Caribbeans instead and
uh yeah you know ipadvisor restarts the
presentation regenerated but restarts it
in the first slide but if I hit this
button it's just going to script the
intro slides and go to the part where we
zoom in on Latin America and the
Caribbeans and then what we did here
actually was we uh yeah we show the
changes uh based on the different
scenarios and then we add a new data
that shows how many births and deaths
are for casted to the these periods by
the UN so you know births are the the
metrics that that make this chart go up
and this and negative net migration are
the things that make it go down and and
this story is about uh comparing the
different forecasts uh by region in
terms of burst deaths and migration
check it out but more even more
interestingly there's uh senior data
scientists working extremely called
Zachary Blackwood I can't praise him
enough because he built a bi-directional
component of IPI Visa into streamlit
basically uh making a couple of nifty
features available within streamlit and
ipadvisor so here's for example a racing
bar chart and you can interactively
switch between the different years with
this slider even so you can you can even
make more complex interactive reports or
data explorers now within streamlit
using uh using this bi-directional
component it's just one python file it's
basically if else things how you add
these widgets so for example this is the
music revenues data set that you're
already familiar with and just going to
extend the year here I'm going to change
instead of the the actual value to
adjust it for inflation or to switch to
volume or to switch to the format so
agree by format and then like let's add
all the formats
and uh and you know there was something
wrong and then sorted by value it's
still in the making and even more
importantly
there's a download story button here so
you have an interactive animated data
report here I just download this report
here and as an HTML file and I open it
up and I don't know about the glitch
that happened before but yeah so here we
have an iPad this is a story that anyone
using streamlit can generate without
having to see one line of python code so
I just you know clicked around in a in
an interactive Explorer and I created a
presentation for myself
this is an important step forward
because it shows what visual is capable
of and what we're working towards to
intertwine exploration and storytelling
I I right now these activities are
totally separated you you have to
analyze the data this what happens to
you all the time you analyze the data
and then as a separate act you start
building charts to to actually share the
insights with others whereas our
Paradigm is that analyze the data
visually and then you will have the
story as a byproduct so that's that's
where we're coming from and this is this
is an important first example of that uh
and yeah we have the the chat GPT Alpha
thing that uh I I will try to use okay
this is the second time I'm using it so
I I'm just adding a file a CSV file to
it uh for a change it's going to be the
music history thing that's what I'm most
familiar with uh I have to change this
to Dimension because uh yeah it's inter
so like it thinks that year is a measure
we know why and describe what we should
see on the chart give me give me a
suggestion please what what should it
what should it build it might not work
so it's an awful version but give me one
suggestion you know the data set already
it's the music formats how much revenue
you generated over the years in the US
line chart
Revenue over time okay
give me a line
chart of Revenue over time
I think suspense it's built in it's a
built-in feature
and we have a line chart of Revenue over
time excuse me
uh I think it's four
but as you can guess it wasn't me
engineering the prompt okay uh one more
because it cost us money you know
bubble chart with year
Revenue color is format
and uh yeah so
it's it's something not done by GPT that
uh I've obviously will animate between
these charts that it builds
there we go
okay my I think the favorite sample uh
that my CTO built or gave to me is like
something interesting for a 40 year old
uh
let's see let's see what we see
um it's yeah it did the same it was it
was it was Revenue by year for DVDs so
it's it's actually DVD Revenue I I don't
know why it thinks that 40 year olds are
interested in DVD but that's a that's a
bias that GPT definitely has
um all right
um so I mean I would I would love to see
some of the stories that you people
build if you want to show it to the
others uh I would love to see that for
everybody here there's just one last
favor that I would like to ask you is to
go at this link and spend two or three
minutes of your time right now if
possible because this is where you have
the most recent experience with what we
do and answer a couple of questions for
us about data storytelling about your
job about ipy vizu about streamlit uh I
I would really appreciate that I mean
thanks
in the meantime I'm happy to answer more
questions while you're most of them are
just multi like you know you have to
pick one option so it's it's going to be
fairly easy for you to to go through
oh you're so good to me yeah please
um
so the question was that from the
security standpoint the exported HTML
file has all the data in it and that
it's it's a security risk as you said
yes it is uh so in many cases uh what I
suggest to people especially when they
want to share uh the stories that they
built online in social media or whatnot
is to make a video of it to use any kind
of screencasting software we all have
those or most of us have those on our
computers actually streamlined has one
built in in their platform uh and and
you can just record the video uh of of
your story and obviously that won't have
the data itself
in it yes there was a question in the
back
uh
question was about the the guidelines
for maximum data set size
um we I mean we we tested it quite
intensely with tens of thousands of data
points being visualized and it ran
pretty well so with a C plus plus engine
in the background and with using
webassembly it's it's really robust
already we have some ideas to improve it
and also to use uh I always messed it up
but no we will use opengl to make it
even more quick and robust
usually you don't want more so
visualizing more than 10 000 data points
don't really make much sense to the
viewer there are special cases but yeah
in in most cases that should be enough
there's a question in the back
so normally or in many languages
thank you
ahead of time
data frame that has
the why and then say okay you're gonna
do
harder
I tried to rephrase the question the way
I understood it and let me know if
that's correct so uh
our tool was compared to other charting
Solutions where you actually create the
data frame or like simplify the data
frame and do the aggregation yourself
that you add to the Chart usually those
are like that night might be the
original data frame and and these are
especially like in many cases these are
just small smaller data frames compared
to the data that you're working with
whereas our case is different is that
right is this what you mentioned
the other way around
the aggregation of specifying the
aggregation option okay sorry about that
yeah that would have been the other
angle but I wasn't sure so
right now we aggregate the data
automatically and that's the only thing
we do but there is a new version of
visual coming up why of which you will
be able to do different operations like
uh show the the average or demand the
Max and and things like that so
basically a built-in pandas manipulation
option within uh the The visu
Tool uh if if that's correct or that's
one way to put it the reason why we have
to do it and that's important to to note
that with every other charting solution
you have usually one view of the data
set that you want to show one chart with
ours is totally different you have
multiple views of the same data set that
you want to put into a story or a chain
of animation and because of that we have
to do the aggregation within the visual
part and and some data manipulations
there so the the use case is different
and thus we we cannot employ the data
manipulation logic that that other
charting Solutions are are easy so to to
use for so are easier to to employ in
them
everything
kind of aggregated with the sum right
yeah yeah and so
okay the question was if I'm sorry to
repeat that this is for the recording
part so the question was if uh every
value is aggregated as sum and then the
count part is like I have to add you
have to add a new column with one in
each row and that's the case right now
so that was in the example with the
Titanic data set that I I before I
loaded it I added this extra column
there I it it yeah it's an early stage
thing and there are some extra Hoops you
have to go through no no thanks I mean
I'm just you know trying to I think it's
a fair point we're working towards uh
addressing it and make it easier for you
to use this thing
another question over there
uh plan of monetization so good news we
don't want to charge the data scientist
now honestly we
we never intended and we know that you
are used to using free tools and we also
know that you have a high level of
expertise in what you do and and you
that's why you can already use our tool
there are plenty of people out there I
would call them Excel users or basic
business users who don't have the kind
of expertise that you do and for whom
these capabilities visual exploration
easily building animated data stories
combining these two things together
would be valuable enough to to get there
while it's open so we want to build a
SAS tool for example that's like the
main
framework of what we're thinking about
with Integrations into Excel for example
and and Export options to PowerPoint and
then you can put a price tag on that
that's that's for sure
yes please uh what license do you use
for the uh what license do we use Apache
2.0
alrighty we have a couple of minutes
left
yes please
springlet
when will that be available and what's
the data security situation there
um so uh the question is about the
streamlined bit and when it would be
available so funny thing if you go to
intro to visual in streamlit.app
and you know check out the repo behind
it's already available we just haven't
started promoting it yet and you can
expect some things to go sideways since
it's Alpha uh
can add on
add-ons yeah it's it's a it's an add-on
it's it's a component within it's a
bi-directional component written by
Zachary that you have to clone into the
repo that you use in order to use
ipivizu in this interactive manner
otherwise uh the streamlit has the basic
logic of refreshing the app all the time
and basically this bi-directional
component addresses that issue along
other ways along other Nifty features
like for example drill down on click so
you can if I click on this bar we are
just going to zoom in and see and drill
down to that component that's just one
example so there are some other features
you can get actually data out of out of
it and and have information about the
marker that's just been clicked and and
use it somewhere else but but you can
use it just look for streamlit hash vizu
uh in on on GitHub and you'll find the
repo we're actually would be happy for
you to to try and test it and let us
know where it went so ways any of you
who started fiddling with the uh with I5
is the story right now can we see it is
there something you've built so far I
just maybe just one transition that we
can take a look if you do please just
upload it to GitHub somehow and give me
the link because it will be hard to
change the laptop right now
uh and uh no really because you know of
the recording thing but uh I would love
to show that maybe maybe you don't have
it yet I'll have to wait for another
Workshop to make that happen and make
our stuff easier to use
um we have time for maybe one or two
more questions yes
and definitely give it a try a question
about the chat GPT integration whether
we plan to open source it and enable
people to use with their own open AI API
key yeah absolutely
um I mean this is a fun project uh I I
actually have do you want to see another
fun project that we're doing as a
closing session
uh actually that's what uh I mean our
so the person with the original idea
behind visual
doesn't know how to code at all he hates
coding he hates spreadsheets so you can
imagine his State of Mind when we
released an open source JavaScript
library and then a python tool for data
scientists and even with that he has
already written more than I don't know
500 examples in JavaScript and python
using our tool but still it's very hard
for him to to get acquainted with this
but let me yeah I think it's going to be
only in this browser
[Music]
um
so this is again just a fun demo that
our CTO put together and and it shows
how
basically how flexible our engine is now
and we're approaching the thing when
we're building on products for the end
users is I think pretty close so we call
it the swipe them over the data Explorer
here you have a data set that's one
chart generated of it it doesn't matter
what data is there I have a touch laptop
you have to know that and hopefully yeah
you can see my my finger swiping through
the screen so I'm just swiping through
different values here
until my ad block is being updated
um sorry about that so I'm just swiping
through his things like this and uh I
can also change the categorical series
on the x-axis I'm just going to switch
to a data set that only has positive
values I can add one more category on
the color scale and I can change that
with a swipe too and and then you know
keep on changing the categories here I
can add another continuous value like
this and and yet another one that gets
on the size and now I can just compare
how things align if I keep on changing
the values or keep on changing the
categories
and uh so imagine what kind of tool can
be built on this technology for anyone
to go through a new data set while I
don't know sitting on the toilet with
their phones in their hands or something
like that so this is what we're working
towards I'm here all throughout the
conference I would love to have your
feedback uh talk about new use cases
ideas uh get to know why are things
sucks and what we should do to fix it so
I'm really not here to fish for
compliments I I'm I'm really happy to
get that kind of feedback as well and
thanks again for for accompanying me on
this 90 minutes of a workshop and and
for your attention thank you
foreign